翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Kyoko Kamura
大変お待たせいたしました
これが私の舞台衣装の
義足用のハイヒールです
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
嬉しい（笑）
まず一つ皆さんに質問があります
誰かに何かを伝えたいとき
または 誰かと解り合いたいときに
あなたなら どんな方法を採りますか？
言葉でしょうか？
身体と身体のぶつかり合いでしょうか？
残念ながら 私は
そういうコミュニケーションは
全く信じられません
私とあなたの間に高い壁や
遠い遠い距離があったら
そんな直接的な方法
何の意味も無いと思ってしまうんです
どうしてそういう捻くれた性格に
なってしまったかと言いますと
私は小さい頃に
スーパーいじめられっ子でした
いじめっ子達がどんなに私をつねっても
私の痛みは彼らには伝わらないし
どんなにSOSを発信しても
同じ日本語を喋っている筈の
先生やクラスメートにも
誰にも通じませんでした
それでも「友達が欲しい！」
と思った私は
いろんな手で あの手この手を使って
気を惹かせようとします
一番よく使ったのが
友達を物で釣るということでした
当時流行の文房具とかグッズを
学校へ持って行って
チラッチラッと見せるんですけど
結局 いつの間にか
隠されて捨てられていたり
人気のキャラクターの絵を
漫画が得意だった私が描いて
そうすると
大人達は褒めてくれるんですけど
それで褒められて掲示されても
結局 傷がつけられて
破られてあったりして
さすがに物で釣る方法は
ダメだったか
でも色々コミュニケーション
というものを考えたけど
やっぱり 私には無理だと
コミュニケーションというものを
諦めた時
私は高校に入って
友達を絶対に作らないと決めました
そして 義足に絵を描き始めます
私は 何て言うんですかね？
イモ虫が鳥を威嚇すべく
触角を出すように
どんどん ド派手な 過激なファッションに
傾倒して行くことになります
するとびっくりしたことに
いじめがぱったりと止んでしまったんです
「誰も近づかないで！私に関わらないで！」
という意思が通じたかのように
本当に誰も
私に関わろうとしないんです
その時に初めて
「あ コミュニケーションが出来た
私の意思が通じたんだ」
とすごく嬉しくなりました
私は見た目で表現することによって
いじめというものをなくし
コミュニケーションの新たな一つの
方法を得ることになります
それからというもの 私は言葉にならない
気持ちや 色んな思い出 そういうものを
何かを作ることという表現に
投げていきます
そこでは怒りや哀しみ喜び
どんな経験も 思い出も
全てが 糧になりました
公園に落ちている木の実や 枝 葉っぱ
古着 針と糸 絵の具
色んなものが製作の材料になりました
義足もその中の一つでした
2005年
「群馬青年ビエンナーレ」という
美術の公募展がありました
そこに私の義足が アート作品として
出品されることになります
16歳の私にとって
「アートって何なんだ？」と
分からないまま
なんと その義足が
奨励賞を取ってしまいます
それがきっかけで 私は 美術の世界
というものに足を踏み入れることになります
そうやって私の義足 私の足
それは色んな世界へと
私を連れて行ってくれることになります
時には私をモデルとしてステージに立たせて
ファッションショーに出させてくれたり
女優としてテレビに出させてくれたり
そして今
このTEDxの舞台に立っているように
私の義足は色んなところに連れて行って
色んな人に思いを伝える方法と
なってくれました
私にとってアートとは
越えられない壁を越えるハシゴや
その壁すら爆発させる爆弾
遠い遠い距離にいる誰かに伝える
伝書鳩のような役割を持っています
まず最初に私 ハイヒールの舞台衣装に
替えますと言いましたが
実はこれはアートプロジェクトの一つとして
パフォーマンスなのです
５年前 私は田舎のジャズ・バーで
歌を歌って仕事をしていました
酔っ払ったお客さんが
「ハイヒールを履かない女なんて
女じゃないだろ！」と
お酒をかけて 野次を飛ばして
きたことがあったのです
私はお酒をかけられたことよりも
なんか 自分の中で
「これは出来ないだろうな」と思って
諦めていたことを指摘されたようで
つつかれたようで
すごく悔しくなって
東京にある義肢製作所に駆け込みます
そこで 「今ある義足の部品の中で
一番高いハイヒールが履ける部品が欲しい」と
それで自分の為に 「ハイヒールを履く」
というプロジェクトを立ち上げました
義足でハイヒールを履くということは
そう簡単ではありません
一番高いハイヒールが履ける部品を
世界で一つだけ作っている会社から
取り寄せて
義足を調整して そして
歩行訓練をし
私はハイヒールで歩けるようになりました
そのハイヒールプロジェクトを
活動して行くうちに
自分の中で
自分の為だけのアートではない可能性
というものが見えてきました
というのも 福祉における当事者
福祉の中で義足を使う者
「うむ 自分て障がい者だったんたな」と
改めてというか もしかしたら初めて
自分を障がい者として自覚することに
なったのがきっかけだったと思います
それで驚いたことに
街に出ると
色んな人の視線が私に
ばっと集中するんですね
「何だ？」と
別に私はえらいことを言っている訳でも
良いことを言っている訳でも
なんかこう 奇抜なおかしなことを
やっている訳じゃないのに
ちょっと私がつまずきそうになったり
何かあったり 挙手動作一つ一つに
みんなの注目が こう
「あ 大丈夫？」みたいなことを
言ってくれたりする訳です
そしてなんと私の声が
まるで拡声器を通した声のように
遠い遠い先の人にまで
伝わるようになりました
この時に初めて
自分の為だけでないアート
という使い方があるんだと
確信しました
このハイヒールは当事者と社会を繋げる
何かの役に立つのではないかと
道具になるのではないか？
と思いました
「アート」と言われると
当時の私の昔の16歳の私のように
難しいことと捉[え]がちですが
実は結構 簡単なことだったりします
アートは決して 美しいものを美しく
見せる為だけの道具ではありません
きっと 私や誰か
誰かの気持ちをどこかへ届ける
一つの方法 一つの道具
なのかも知れません
世の中というのは
多面的で常に輝いています
それは私たちも同じです
歳を取るごとに
時代が変わっていくように
その輝きというのは
どんどん増えていって
もう言葉だけでは追いつきません
そんな時 アートという方法は
とても役に立つと思います
きっと私やあなたの輝きに触れる何か
きっかけや道具になってくれるはずです
是非ともアートを使って身近な人の
または 身近な世界の輝きに
触れてみて下さい
それでは最後に
私の今の気持ちを表現したいと思います
私に触れてみて下さい
（音楽始まり）
（歌「愛の讃歌」）
あなたのその腕で
わたしを抱きしめて
ただ二人だけで
生きていたいの
ただ命の限り
あなたを愛したい
命の限りに
あなたを愛するの
頬と頬よせ
燃えるくちづけ
交わすよろこび
あなたと二人で 暮らせるものなら
なんにもいらない
あなたと二人
生きて行くのよ
わたしの願いは ただそれだけよ
あなたと二人
固く抱き合い
燃える指に髪を
からませながら
いとしみながら
くちづけを交わすのよ
愛こそ燃える火よ
わたしを燃やす火
心燃やす恋よ
（拍手）
ありがとうございました
（歓声）
ありがとうございます
足が震える…